un caso positivo por coronavirus envió a
las grandes estrellas del tenis de nuevo
a aislamiento unas 520 personas entre
jugadores y demás acreditados para el
australian open tendrán que someterse a
pruebas después de que un caso positivo
fuera detectado en un trabajador del
hotel grand hyatt todos los partidos en
los eventos previos fueron suspendidos
para este jueves sin embargo el riesgo
es bajo
el último caso en salir del hotel de
salud fue el día 22 pasaron cerca de 14
días desde ese momento así que si hubo
alguna exposición estarían llegando a
ese periodo ahora así que pensamos que
el riesgo es relativamente bajo así que
es por esto que estamos haciendo pruebas
para estar seguros pero de nuevo es por
precaución
aunque los organizadores dicen que no
hay garantías creen que el primer gran
slam del año que debe comenzar el lunes
podrá realizarse
estamos absolutamente confiados de que
el abierto australia se va a realizar
sabemos que tuvimos un periodo que hemos
tenido que superar con esos 507
jugadores y su personal son 160
jugadores de hecho que necesitan una
prueba y contamos plenamente con que la
posibilidad es muy baja que no habrá
ningún problema esperamos que todos
ellos de negativo y luego continuaremos
con el juego mañana como lo planeamos
originalmente si los jugadores dan
negativo podrán retomar la competición
el estado cde del grand slam ha sufrido
uno de los cierres más grandes y duros
del mundo para contener el nuevo
coronavirus y el caso del miércoles fue
el primero adquirido localmente en el
estado en casi un mes